okay so that trailer was amazing oh my
god the trailer was amazing okay so
what's happening in this movie right
just from what we saw with the trailer
what's going on in this movie okay a few
things that we know are happening right
uh marvel studios sony whatever you want
to call them are basically borrowing
part of the story line from brand new
day what's brand new day brand new day
was the aftermath to civil war at least
the aftermath to one more day which was
the aftermath civil war the important
thing here is that during civil war as a
demonstration that uh spider-man
believed in the superhuman registration
act he publicly revealed his identity to
the world brand new day was a story that
was written where dr strange basically
wiped that knowledge from the minds of
everybody on earth that's what it looks
like they're doing in at least part of
the movie here the question is how do we
get from a to b how do we get from that
point where doctor strange is cashing
the spell to all this craziness okay
well the trailer basically tells us
spider-man because of the fact that he
probably has to think a certain thing or
he has to believe a certain thing or
stay still and silent whatever it is
he's supposed to do he's not doing so he
basically disrupts the spell and instead
of the spell going off without a hitch
it basically creates a divergent
timeline in the multiverse now we kind
of knew that was something that was
coming anyway right if you guys remember
that scene from loki where the
multiverse was coming back you did see
universal branches coming off but you
also saw universes crossing through
other universes which is basically the
idea that universes can cross paths
right they can actually merge or they
can pass through phase through that kind
of a thing and that's what i think is
happening that with the multiverse and
everything running awry and if i'm being
honest it might be even a little bit of
involvement with regards to loki one
division that's kind of impacting what's
going on in spider-man the important
thing here is that i think what happened
here is that with the spell being
screwed up that now peter parker is
phase shifting right one of the things
we're kind of seeing in these different
scenes is you don't really see doctor
strange anymore after that initial
moment when the spell's cast and
everything goes wrong and so it looks
like it's just spider-man tom holland we
didn't see toby mcguire we didn't see
andrew garfield and fingers crossed that
we do get to see them later on remember
when marvel released the first trailer
for civil war we didn't see spider-man
we didn't see him in the civil war film
until the second trailer so that's
something to bear in mind when it comes
to the appearance of characters over the
course of different you know spider-man
marvel related properties you know now
that i think about it though we do see
doctor strange a couple times in that
trailer beyond like the original spell
okay so i was wrong about that so maybe
it's him and spider-man who are lost in
the time stream and it's like sliders
right like literally they're just trying
to find their way back to the main
universe but they can't because it's
like trying to find a needle in a stack
of needles maybe that's the whole deal
the important thing here is that what i
think's happening is that because it all
went wrong peter parker is basically
phase shifting through universes that's
what i think is essentially happening
here that the whole spell goes off
everything goes nuts and then you know
tom holland wakes up and he's in a
universe with alfred molina spider-man
and that is one of those things where
like because he's there as spider-man uh
maybe you know the like toby maguire is
off doing something else and tom holland
just happens to appear where alfred
molina's doctor octopus is and then he's
just kind of like well hello spider-man
right because he thinks that tom holland
is actually toby mcguire cue the scene
where toby maguire shows up and now you
got two spider-man facing off against
doctor octopus shift universes and then
you end up with electro the version
that's played by jamie foxx who as far
as i'm aware has come out and said
that's not the same electro from the
andrew garfield spider-man universe but
if andrew garfield is going to appear in
this movie then it makes sense that it
actually is maybe just some version that
has more technological enhancements
whatever the case happens to be but
andrew garfield and tom holland team up
they defeat uh electro phase shift to
the next universe and it's like that
over and over and over again right phase
shift into different universes until he
finally manages to find a way back home
or he can't there's no possible way for
him to get back to his native universe
and so in effect tom holland is lost in
the multiverse right he's just literally
lost in his multiversal space and he
will stay lost until the events of
doctor strange two and doctor strange
two is what will lead to him being
rescued and then brought back to the
marvel cinematic universe this is
awesome you know why this is awesome
because if that's the case it lends the
possibility right it lends the
possibility that in into the multiverse
2 right spider-man into the multiverse 2
that animated movie with miles morales
tom holland could appear there he just
stumbles across their universe why
because in that series spider-man into
the multiverse and even in marvel comics
as a whole you have something called the
web warriors what are the web warriors
it's a multiversal spider-man team it's
literally a team of spider-man from
different universes that all team up and
kind of fight various threats throughout
the multiverse that maybe tom holland
ends up just kind of coming along and
just sort of hanging out with that team
maybe we don't see him again maybe we
won't see hide nor hair of tom hall and
spider-man until doctor strange too
maybe at the end of it he ends up going
back to his native universe maybe the
whole thing is that he doesn't the deal
that was worked out between sony and
marvel is that sony gets to keep tom
hall and spider-man and marvel gets
miles morales hence the reason why we
saw donald glover in spider-man 2 and
basically was like yeah man like my
nephew miles morales exists in this
universe because that's the spider-man
that we're going to get going forward in
the marvel cinematic universe instead of
tom holland i don't know i have no real
clue right it's just a trailer there's
only so much we can glean from this but
there are huge possibilities here and i
am so excited about this by the way man
the green goblin oh my god that green
goblin laugh man that was the stuff of
legend god that was so cool right seeing
that little green goblin bomb that
little pumpkin bomb it doesn't really
look like a pumpkin bomb but it looks
like a bomb from the green goblin and
then like you hear his laugh
oh my god dude this trailer had so many
cool
moments in it one of the other things
that i noticed too is that when you have
like the the bomb of the green goblin
that gets thrown and you hear his laugh
and then you see like alfred molina's uh
doctor octopus it all looks like it's in
the same location right like they're on
the bridge maybe that's where like the
climactic battle takes place and then
again it ends on this idea that they
can't get back to their home universe
they're basically lost in the time
stream so maybe that's really where dr
strange two picks up that it picks up
with doctor strange and spider-man lost
in the time stream trying to find a way
to make their way back stumble across
like america chavez and then like shuma
gorath is chasing after her and then
you're right into doctor strange too
right maybe it really is spider-man is
part one doctor strange two is part two
they're basically two parts of
essentially the same story being told
over two films like you saw with
infinity war and avengers in-game and i
am so excited about this i mean it
really begs the question like what comes
out of all of this right how is this
whole thing going to progress into the
future of the marvel cinematic universe
with this whole multiversal thing going
on i mean honestly man and i've been
i've been saying this for a long time
i've been saying this for a long long
time i really hope we end up getting the
multiversal avengers out of this right
that's that's what i'm really hoping
because right now loki's experience with
the multiverse doctor strange has some
measure of experience with the
multiverse you'll have more experience
when it goes into the multiverse of
madness because even in the trailer he
said we don't know really anything about
the multiverse now that kind of begs the
question why why don't they really know
anything about the multiverse i mean we
know the ancient ones seem to understand
the multiverse the ancient one seemed to
grasp the multiverse but even her
explanation was pretty surface right the
multiverse an infinite number of
universes some of them are really really
cool and like utopian and like a
paradise and then some of them are just
terrible and they house dorlamu and he
wants to conquer everything and that's
all we got
that's really all we got for her but
presumably we'd have to believe based on
her age that the the ancient one knows a
lot about the multiverse so seemingly
you would expect doctor strange to seem
to seem like he knows as much about the
multiverse but if the multiverse has
been dead for a while for like a long
long time and like we talked about in
the loki video the ancient one was
around when the multiversal war between
all the kings happened and now when the
multiverse ended and that was the only
universe left because her and immortus
worked together to make it that way then
sure she has a knowledge a lot of
knowledge about the multiverse but
doctor strange doesn't because it's not
around there's nothing to teach him
about the multiverse it's just now
coming back and so he's basically flying
by the seat of his pants trying to learn
how the multiverse works but doesn't
really have any answers because it
literally showed up yesterday so like he
doesn't really know anything about it
and so with that kind of a kind of a
thing taking place there's a lot of
multiversal
exploration to be had here doctor
strange is going to learn a lot of
experience about the multiverse scarlet
witch is already in the multiverse we
know that from the end of juan division
and now tom holland and spider-man is
going to have exposure to the multiverse
it's entirely possible that at the end
of all this it just comes together in
the form of a multiversal avengers team
sometimes they face off against
multiversal threats sometimes they don't
i've been saying secret defenders i
think is going to be coming for from a
long long time ago right secret
defenders was like a comic written in
the 1990s and the whole idea was that
doctor strange would basically gather
together a group of different
superheroes and the roster changed all
the time and they would go and fight
like mephisto or dormammu or nightmare
or something like that that's entirely
possible here right like literally if if
spiderman disappears at the end of no
way home right there's no way for him to
get back and the movie ends based on its
namesake which is there's no conceivable
way for spider-man to get back to his
native universe and he's basically lost
in the multiverse then
and dr strange grabs him during doctor
strange too then now you have doctor
strange and you have tom holland who are
likely gonna face off against the
scarlet witch or the scarlet witch will
come to their aid alongside possibly
loki while they face off against like
the was it schuma gorath who's supposed
to be chasing down america chavez who
then joins the group as well so now you
got five people who are experienced in
the multiverse facing off against some
threat and then boom you got the
multiversal avengers or the secret
defenders if you want to call them that
doctor strange super super you know
super secret superhero team whatever you
want to call it man it doesn't really
matter but like this leads to incredible
possibilities in the mcu man and i am so
excited but that trailer was amazing god
i wish i wish i was a time variance
authority man i could just rewind time
or fast forward time and just be like
hey guys so the trailer just came out
now i'm gonna fast forward timing go
watch the movie like i wish i could do
that man but i'm not gonna be able to
sleep tonight i'm so excited man it's
gonna it's gonna it's gonna be difficult
man
i'm sorry i'm so excited people
but but it is an exciting time right it
is it is
an exciting time
you guys you guys know what i'm saying
man it's an amazing moment it's an
amazing moment the trailer was cool
god i loved it anyway guys i'm gonna go
ahead and bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later peace
you